this year for the first time in 25 years
former president donald trump was not on
the forbes 400 list he fell short of
making the list by 400 million dollars
of course trump remains immensely
wealthy with a net worth of 2.5 billion
dollars here's how his portfolio breaks
down as of september this year his new
york real estate holdings are worth 1.1
billion dollars making up 42 percent of
his wealth most notable are his stake in
1290 avenue of the americas which has a
net value of 346 million dollars and
trump tower with a net value of 185
million dollars next are his golf clubs
and resorts worth 650 million dollars
and 26 of his wealth he also owns 10
golf courses in six states and
washington dc as well as three golf
courses in europe in addition there's
the famous mar-a-lago club in palm beach
which is worth an estimated 300 million
dollars cash and personal assets make up
450 million dollars or 18 percent of his
wealth these include about 300 million
dollars in cash three homes in florida a
country home in bedford new york his
penthouse and trump tower a home in
saint martin two airplanes and one
helicopter trump's non-new york real
estate holdings are worth 310 million
dollars or 12 percent of his wealth
these include 30 percent of 555
california street in san francisco
stakes in trump hotels in las vegas
washington dc and chicago and a winery
in charlottesville virginia to top it
all off trump's brand businesses are
worth 58 million dollars or 2 percent of
his wealth since trump's presidency his
branding business has not fared well
trump can blame his divisive reputation
built on years of controversial comments
and boosted by the january 6th attack on
the u.s capitol
you